nella city ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono ma vj ragazzi prima di
cominciare con soltanto a farmi una
piccola premessa come videogioco che
state per vedere è una cosa senza senso
che volete
prendi diciamo in giro i fumatori perché
dunque fumare è una cosa che fa male non
serve a niente
prima di cominciare appunto volevo dirvi
che ragazzi non fumate mai è una cosa
che non serve assolutamente una
stronzata quindi non fatelo per nessun
motivo al mondo perché veramente è una
cosa inutile
ci devo le spire ragazzi la mia opinione
sul fatto prima di cominciare scusatemi
se voluto farlo è giusto pertanto a
salvi maroni come al solito prima che
inizi il vino e detto queste ragazzine
che possiamo cominciare bella tutti i
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
sono fa vj ci siano su uno dei
videogiochi più strani che io abbia mai
fatto niente si chiama smoking simulator
è praticamente è un simulatore di fa
piacere che park cos'è il giorno 1
lavoro e di mente dovrebbe essere un
simulatore di nervosismo quindi devo
fumare altro pubblicità occulta gol con
le marche di sigarette e fantastico devo
farlo devo lavorare al computer the
company mica che non originale per una
compagnia fantastico e ha fatto giocare
nessun divertimento lavoro vai a fare
più soldi ma [ __ ] regala già sta
cosa mi sta innervosendo e qui fatto
male e sono incazzate devo portare suo
zio tanto devo buttare giù si sta
facendo demolendo il ufficio perché non
potevo giocare video che ho resistito un
giorno dopo
già verso ragazzo hanno durato tre
secondi di merda fantasia prima interna
devo svolgere attività dal lavoro senza
innervosirmi allora io acquisto tutto
[ __ ] al mondo boss vieni nel mio
ufficio adesso ho detto adesso l'ho già
presa nel colore mi vorrà dire
sicuramente che sono un bravissimo
dipendente adesso ho capito poi
bellissimo che parte la musica di slam
io non l'ho mai visto un boss in vita
perché fa la faccia lei incazzato quando
incassato però vabbè io fumo è scattato
l'allarme antincendio si pone anche
fumare adesso fa fantastico ai ragazzi
di andare in ufficio perché è
leggermente incazzarsi arrivo testa di
minchia arrivo ci sia la panarello e lo
stende
perché perché siamo slider man come
poste e si spiega anche la musica di
sottofondo adesso rage mode sono andato
in regime allora fammi entrare che le
viole via testate si può devi morire che
sopra ho mandato letteralmente all'aria
la l'ufficio del vostro delle morire
atrocemente sulle tue fottute pagine tuo
[ __ ] ufficio ma ho lette tutte mi
hanno licenziato con le morto appena ho
appena ucciso una persona fantastica
lo adoro è bellissimo dai basta cioè io
ero convintissimo delle provati giochi
più strani della terra mamma maggioro
che questo li supera tutti cosa stai
facendo
io mi spacco il culo a lavoro e tutti fa
i cazzi tuoi
levati dalla mia festa che cosa orribile
rega è ok allora sentite
basta fare il [ __ ] prova a farlo
seriamente perché mi piace far casino in
ufficio non lo metto in dubbio dai
ragazzi programma farlo seriamente dai
nostri riesco a va magari riesce bene
lavoro d'ufficio non lo so se non lo
scoprirò mai se non ci provo
usciamo di qualche ancora nessuno s'è
incazzato per miracolo cosa incredibile
mia moglie i genitori saranno con noi
cosa no non puoi dirmi sta stronzata
adesso mi renda fumare fatemi uscire
fatemi uscire veloci veloci devo fumare
devo fare si può fare non sbloccare la
perfetto si fuma fumo veloce rea ma che
bella all'aria aperta ai polmoni che si
purificano ragazzi non opportuno possono
dirmi se cose sentii lurida [ __ ] tu
non inviti in nessuno o ti prende a
schiaffi chi questo non ce la faccia
denti zio wayne a mano non può che mi
sembra che stia svendendo sa lavoro
massacra a dir poco non si può fuggire
si può scavare col muro non si può fare
forse è meglio di non fatemi fumare
ancora un pochettino perché se no no no
fini tosi che il cazzo di andare a
prenderci dirette e sentite io so chi
cazzo sei tu mi fa troppa paura è che
esistono gioco abbiate pazienza fatevi
prende una sigaretta che sto di nuovo
morendo ragazzi ovviamente il boss mi ha
convocato nell'ufficio perché sennò non
è contento madonna quanto tv a ributtare
tutti sti quadri non c'ha idea ripari
your self sono pronto cos'è la madonna
allora sentite soffermarti in faccia
vero tipo skatar arti sugli occhi ecco
perfetto la cosa mi dice di no però
almeno gli piove in faccia almeno quello
che voglio vedere che cosa succede
quando ecco quando quando gli arrivi
davanti quindi manda me mi manda
messaggi che sono dietro la porta
vantaggio è proprio la comunicazione a
voce sparita
come mai sta urlando di preciso non lo
senti l'uomo lupo hai qualcosa da dirmi
hanno capito perché si mette a tua madre
solo adesso perché prima era una
bellissima giornata adesso no ok a mia
mi ha rimandato lavora non è successo un
cazzo d'accordo ragazzi mi prende una
pausa per fare un attimino un giretto
per vedere con me a questo al bagno
degli uomini hanno vincolo delle donne
più giusto per vedere se succede
qualcosa può sapere si apre c'è nessuna
ha prodotto ragazzi quest'uomo un
pervertito quindi apro qualsiasi porta
mi si parlava non c'è nessuno nel bagno
delle donne ma ci vado perché non sono
un gentleman il bagno si può fumare ma
mi sa che ci sono 16 i sensori anche in
bagno spiegate nell'asta cosa non l'ho
capita le prognosi dicono che devi
smettere di fumare cazzo mi ha mandato
al dottor esposto messaggio alla
famiglia mi devo mettere a fumare perché
giustamente quando un dottore mi dice di
smettere di fumare io per la tensione
vado a fumare perché mi sembra giusto
allora fatemi ok adesso sono più calmo
no come si mette via la sigaretta come
cazzo momento via se questa cosa non
l'ho capita ancora togli la c'è un modo
mano che la butto che è non lo so
ditemelo sentite mamma poi in ufficio
perché cazzo avete le sigarette nelle
caramelle
questo me lo dovete spiegare che offre
perfetto ragazzi facciamoci una tazza
senza caffè meravigliose razzista
ufficio è una merda un po come la tua
faccia diciamo pochettino si voglia fare
un attimino giro per le scale scale c'è
anche il tetto non ci sono casi no cosa
ti sta lasciando per l'uomo della
testimonianza perfetto per capire che
sei una vacca da latte boss se il
ritardo non sono in ritardo testa di
minchia sto solo fumando in giro e non
farmi incazzare perché devo prendere
sigarette da fumare porca ladra l'on
ok ci si auspica per far miracoli calè
qualcuno mi dia una sigaretta cazzo ho
bocciato con la macchina figlio
si possono fare più di due passi
se qualcuno fa una cazzata quindi bella
la sigla della compagnia vanta cotesta
porta cos'è perché chi cazzo sono questi
può far tutto
le statistiche muori per tutti senti tu
michael jackson non è che puoi fare col
cazzo che vuoi togliti 6 indicando il
grafico fantastico la ragazzi io sono
negata o gioco abbiamo capito sta cosa
mi incazzo facilmente e questo voi già
lo sapevate
[Musica]
meno 1035 ok meno sei meno meno 200
dollari
andiamo nel par answers è invitato a fan
culo ma questo lavoro non rompere i
[ __ ] 200 duecento meno 40 sentite mi
fa incazzare sto gioco quando io lavoro
non devo avere casi per la testa perché
sono mi date sul culo ho fatto a saltare
spiegato sono saltato a caso non sentite
io non sono capace a fare lavori
d'ufficio abbiate pazienza lo stato a
demolire qualcosa con un martello però
questo è morta morte sono morti tutti
con mandato a cagare voi e le aule
apposite a una conferenza sono incinta
amante ma stabile mantello l'amante
incinta ed è colpa tua lorido sentite
fatevi prendere un po da che non si può
fare una mazza east uffici possono
fumare e lavorare male tra l'altro
quindi non è possibile
e i belladonna vuoi una mano lavoro ma
perché ti vedo che si è impegnata
sentisse io per caso mi mettessi così e
poi ti facessi annusare le mie mutande
rompermi le palle moglie sto facendo
usare la mia mutande a una dipendente ma
le ragazzine che ha giocato abbastanza
sta roba perché mi pare una cosa allora
io io vi giuro di giochi strani
veramente ne ho giocati tantissimi e lo
sapete ma questo giuro che è che che fa
concorrenza che la metà basta parte gli
scarti non fumate mai perché è una
stronzata megagalattica perché uno fa
male non serva un cazzo e 2 poi per poi
cade l'acqua ad est dai soffitti quindi
non ho fatto a prescindere
prima di concludere ragazzi con canon
attimino mettere un po ecco perfetto
bravo così bello tu che lavori molto
seriamente [ __ ] dovete morire
tutti tu che non hai hanno usato le mie
mutande ragazzi sta cosa è fantastica e
per ultimo per ultimo ma non per
importanza pacchetto di massacrarlo di
testate ma buongiorno amico mio racconta
che non si vediamo se stai male perché
allo stesso giocando
di morire devi morire è morto ragazzi
fantastico mi sa dire che se posso
concludere vi l'episodio perché credo
che però ci di nonsense ne abbia visto
abbastanza non sopporti di ragazze il
viso è piaciuto se non siete nervosi
lasciate un commento mi piace anche a
fagiani facebook e come non i video
collateral descrizione solo se avresti
dismettere ci vediamo al prossimo mito e
ragazzi